he's Vince Carter the Hawks guard /
forward and joins us on the program
Vince good morning how are you I'm doing
well how are you doing I'm doing okay
are you a football fan I am did you ever
play for him I did I was a quarterback
whoa and I'm running back and receiver
are the most of the quarterback wait
were you a running back wide receiver
and quarterback at the same time Vince
were you that good one point at one
point but Mon Ami
extra point and I was a snapper in one
year but mostly I was a quarterback now
as I got taller running back wasn't a
great idea and I was a decent I mean I
was in playing the varsity and until I
got I broke my wrist in a intramural
basketball game and the doctor this is
high school the doctor said you had to
make a decision on a sport because of
you know just a lot of pounding
basketball of course at football cuz
what football is gonna do to me and I
think I made the right decision I think
you did too but I I didn't you'd be
great on blocking extra points and field
goals I'd think oh sure that's living
out of that too I was everywhere man
back in the day in second Taylor as a
young young Vince I I was around the
field I played a little defense table
safety back there uh-huh me ask you know
it's one of those things Pop Warner
football was uh one of those things you
get as many athletes as you could just
teach them a bunch of positions and
obviously as you get older you kind of
fall in place it to a position that is
comfortable or that that works with your
abilities and I fell in love with the
quarterback position and that's
something I did I played what's the most
points you scored in high school
basketball yeah uh fifty in three
quarters and that's eight-minute
quarters in it
yeah yeah but when you see something
like klay Thompson the other night Mike
how many points do you think he could
have had if if they just said you know
what just go go get him clay he was
probably all place to know what pace to
say another eighty point nine I think
and it could I mean like I say it could
be more because the way he was shooting
the three-point shot it was like
shooting mid range too but who do you
think would be the warrior if I said you
got to pick one to get eighty in a game
oh I'm I mean you have to give the clay
right now cuz Buca because he has a
record
he gets the first not what was more
impressive the only reason why I picked
them though that's what i'ma say that
now because like Steph is definitely
capable but we have to pick right now
the record holder and he doesn't have
the ball for I mean everything is
catching shooting either dribble it
potently directly he doesn't grip it
very long and mes impressive he doesn't
need a lot of troubles to kind of get a
shot it's just if I see a clean look I'm
letting to go and it's impressive what's
what's more impressive to you Kobe
ending his career with sixty or Kobe
putting up 81 on Toronto oh if you're
gonna go out and in your career you know
maybe he said I'm gonna go get sixty on
tonight doesn't matter who it is I don't
care how good the defender is I'm
getting 60 on my last game that's
amazing 81 was amazing in itself but I
think when you going out with 60 on your
last game do you think the Hawks would
let you go out like that Vince oh I did
I think it's a situation to squish you
know they weren't going to the
Lakers it just depends on what the
situation looks like and if I'm in a
rhythm order them in relays crazy if I
made a song like that yeah maybe but I
doubt it I mean that feeling of when you
get to shoot whenever you want I mean
that's a great feeling
that's that's a great feeling I mean you
can shoot yourself in rhythm at any
point so you can start off over eight
and still shoot I mean just that's this
is great yeah it's great really all
right if I gave you the opportunity to
write the final chapter here so the
final shot you take in the NBA what kind
of shot and who's guarding you
my final shot I hope nobody's guarded me
no you're gonna make it you're gonna
make you're making it oh now I want it
to be a dump
I really do and who are you dunking over
oh man you know you're still dunking 241
so why not go out on its own yeah thanks
for me to be great to see is even a dump
or a game-winner I'm still if it's a
dunk I want to be by myself so know what
nobody gets hurt for one and if it's a
game-winner you know I want to go out
I'm probably probably dirt because he's
right there with me two old guys going
at it in the sink one game-winning fade
away or something three yeah well for my
guy there
does it hurt more going up for a dunker
coming down from a dunk definitely
coming down thank you ups not bad like I
couldn't yes I mean you and you're up
there to here like go have any time but
this is your friend but when it's had
enough and it kind of disrupts you out
of theirs it's now time for the shock
absorbers that you have or do not have
to take over and some days are better
than others
you know in recent years that's why when
you dunk I try to hold off RAM just to
make sure the landing a little easier
but the way the game is now the pace of
plate you can't do that you know the
longer you hang up there the team is
probably at half-court by the time I
land so it's now it's like hey make sure
you get the two and just get on back
he's Vince Carter the Hawks guard
forward and I was gonna wait to mention
your age you brought up your age so
you're 41 you'll be 42 in January right
yeah Wow 42 just trait okay what it what
is tre young call you beefy oh so he
doesn't go like most of the time every
now and then he comes with og you know
all right but he could be yourself
he could be your son up wild do these
guys know but do you show them like that
before YouTube video and just say hey
just a reminder here you little Punk's
they see and they like you know and
sometimes I go not know I remember okay
I mean when you do this it catches
off-guard but that is less you know like
you know there is hope for these kids
because they're the basketball fans in
fact not only are they just for social
media they're you know they look at in
watch they watch the history of
basketball you know I've been around
long enough so I've played against it's
a lot of history of basketball and you
know and I've done some things before
the history of basketball so these guys
actually watch that because they love
the game like that so it's pretty cool
when one of these young guys will say
something about what they remember from
back in the day when either they weren't
alive or just being born and or just
like young kids I mean some of these
kids like some of the guys some of the
things that I did they were really two
three four years old and probably wasn't
paying attention or remember the game
but they still watched those video clips
thank God for you to enable to put those
V
VHS games on an HD where it still looks
decent would you you know with the
growth of the the three-point shot I
mean it you know basketball has changed
here since Steph Curry came into the
league but if you if you were coming in
now what kind of player would you would
you be the same player yep I still think
I'd be the same player yeah of course
more than likely utilized the three a
little more but I mean if I was young
Vince coming into this league now I
still would I mean attack the rim and do
what I do I mean I believe in you when
you have a player I mean I know the
mid-range game is something something
that you don't teams don't really use or
want used and I wasn't like I didn't use
the mid-range game that much but I mean
it's just something like I want to get
in the paint I wanted to just attack the
rim and the three-point shot is
something I did use it just wasn't used
as much back in the game
I think say this in the late 90s in
shooting and in the 90s at all really
you know it wasn't used and talked about
as much of course the three-point shot
you run you ran plays for it because you
had the great Reggie Miller
you know Rip Hamilton well he's more
mid-range I mean you know Ray Allen
those guys like that who were double
staggered away threes I mean that's
that's what they did but I mean it
wasn't like now having your running
plays where you'll you'll post up a
guard just to get the sinner a
three-point shot on the weak side now I
mean it's just in a different game crazy
did you walk with Tiger when he was at
the PGA Championship I did how come I
did it was great I was I was my really
my first time seeing Tiger live and we
started off my early years we had the
same agent it's just every every time he
would play you know in Orlando he had
his uh Tavistock Cup and the year that I
played in Orlando we were out of town so
I didn't get to see him play there and
it was just a great opportunity I mean
nothing better than to see them here at
Eastlake
competing for a win and almost really
pulling it off being the champ I mean
that it was just is amazing it's amazing
I was at definitely in fan mode that day
I tried to play it cool like yeah you
know it's Tiger school but it was just
it's amazing to see somebody in you know
in the field I mean we all know Tiger
Woods how great he is when you watch it
on TV people when you see something like
that what he did live and understanding
how impactful that was I think deal when
you pulling up on 18 and seeing Matt
crowd follow him and I was already on
the green that was Green side and you
see like everybody walk to nothing like
man where is he all of a sudden Tiger
Woods just Tiger appears out of this
crowd it was it was it was unbelievable
that's a commercial in itself yeah I was
a crazy crazy scene crazy scene I'm
worried about this if if Jordan is the
best player you played against is that
right right yeah okay I did play against
Jordan okay the second-best player you
played against is who I did play against
Kobe Bryant and and LeBron James so I
mean I think right there then I mean I
don't really have an order of yeah I
think in Jays there and then you have
Kobe and the probably the second-best
player than LeBron I mean it's hard to
pick players for me personally because
I'm still planning to those guys you
know and then you know I just once
they're done playing or I'm done playing
and I can really add other players
current players and so I'm just gonna
stick with LeBron mean I would stick
with Mike and then Kobe Kobe wanted to
kill you right he wanted to kill
everybody absolutely absolutely and we
played together and and I think the comp
the level of competition and respect or
the other thing the respect you show
players back is particularly back in
that day was not give them everything
respect at all and and that's that's how
you're you understood that's how that's
what made great basketball first of all
and
either when you play Kobe whether you
weren't having a great day weren't
feeling well you know you better figure
it out because he's gonna be an attack
mode on both ends and he made some great
basketball I think the same things
within chatting - I don't care how old
he was he was still putting up numbers
and for as many players like myself
young guys cold everybody stacked all of
the bars
t-mac everybody who wanted that
opportunity to really make their mark on
MJ it wasn't as easy as you thought he
and he was 40 40 I mean y'all know if
remember to play he caught Ron Marshalls
layup off the glass - and more like you
know I mean it's just it was just
amazing the seeding just a great
challenge I can say that I played in the
elite of the elite in Michael Jordan I
mean I'm looking to all-star Atlanta his
last all-star game I was a starting
guard and I had a brief I don't want to
call it argument but yeah we were just
talking about hey Mike you know this is
your last leg start getting your started
no questions asked and you know Mike was
like a man you earned it you go ahead I
was like man you not get me blackballed
from the NBA and it was just great to be
me it was great it was a great moment to
be a part of though because I that's
like a piece of history for me we
remember that the unbelievable fadeaway
that I felt that we should have ended
the game right there that he hit over
Shawn Marion you know born his last
all-star game but I mean it was just
great to be a part of okay but wait a
minute see in a situation to do that if
Mike went to NC State or Duke instead of
North Carolina would you have given him
your starting role in the all-star game
if he was a thank you okay all right
well you have to because I mean his body
of work and the pedestal that he stands
on demands it demands
all right here's here's the question
I'll leave you with this the greatest
slam dunk er in North Carolina history
is
in North Carolina oh yeah I'll take that
you take him every day everything he's
got everything else no your father he's
right there I mean that's I mean like I
said just walking into that gym I just
want to take that thing I think every
Carolina player will say this Punk GMs
course the first person I think every
person looks for is MJ and we know what
he did in college and of course in the
NBA and his ability to dunk so I said
you know I might not end up being the
greatest player or as good as him but
there's something that I could do that
Kitana have people thinking hey maybe
maybe and so that that off that dunk
contest was one of the things that you
know I made my mark so I studied I know
if we've talked about this I think a lot
of times in person and on the phone is
just the dunk contest was kind of like
pop over to in time where I said I'm
gonna I wanna watch shock the world
awhile out the crowd for years to come I
just didn't you know it it did it's have
its effect like it's had and you know
I'm thankful for it I still wish you
would have taken that music scholarship
to bethune-cookman and played and played
basketball for bethune-cookman instead
of now you had to go play for North
Carolina
whatever no I'm going to Bethune cook
I'm taking my talents too soon cook up
the street and around the corner sorry
Dean Smith legend hey Vince good to have
you on again have fun this season and
always a pretty appreciate catching up
with you always man photography for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show at
you
[Music]